-Gugu, hello, nice to meet you.
Thank you for
coming on the show.
-Thank you.
-I know we're meeting
through Zoom.
It's odd, but I bet you a lot of
people are meeting through Zoom.
-I know. It's crazy.
This is it.
This is how we live now.
-Yeah. This is it.
I was going to ask if you're
in London,
but you're in Atlanta right now,
right?
-I'm in Atlanta right now, yeah.
I'm here.
I just restarted filming here
on "Loki",
the show that I'm working on.
-Oh, "Loki," for Disney+.
-Yeah.
-Disney Plu!
-Disney Plu! Yeah!
-No one calls it that,
but we can start that today.
-There we go.
It's going to be a thing.
-Were you a big Marvel fan
before joining the show?
-You know,
I wasn't a massive fan.
I have to confess,
I wasn't a huge fan,
but I did sort of binge
all the shows before
starting this because,
obviously,
it's inspired by a character
from "Thor"
and there's all
of the "Thor" movies,
so I got Disney Plu,
and I sort of binged
on everything and caught up.
So now I know what I'm doing.
-Many people have taken up
hobbies while in quarantine,
and you posted these portraits
that you painted on Instagram,
and they're gorgeous.
You went from painting people
you know to painting portraits
of the George Floyd
and Breonna Taylor
and John Lewis.
-Yeah.
-What inspired you
to paint their portraits?
-Well, you know, I think,
like everyone, I just found
the shifts that were happening
culturally, you know,
post the murder of George Floyd
and all of the protests that
ensued, and I was painting
every day anyway,
and it was just such a shock,
and just such an emotional time.
Somehow, just being able to
channel those emotions into art
just was sort of a way for me
to process it,
I think, at the time.
And then, you know,
just to be able to paint
Breonna Taylor,
actually took that painting
on a protest with me in L.A.
as a banner, and I wrote
"Say Her Name" on the back,
and was able to actually auction
those two paintings for charity,
for some social justice
organizations as well.
-See?
-Yeah,
it's took on a greater purpose.
-I read that when you're
working as an actor
that you use music to help you
prepare for roles.
Are you musical?
-You know, I like to sing,
and I did grow up
playing the saxophone,
which was really a treat for me.
I haven't played it for a while.
-Oh, I love the saxophone.
That's so tricky.
What made you get into
saxophone?
-Oh, my God. Well, I think,
probably, Lisa Simpson
had a little bit to do with it.
-For real?
-Yeah, for real.
Just watching that show
And just seeing a young girl
just playing the saxophone,
I was like, that is so cool.
I want to do that.
It's possible. And I just was
so inspired by her.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
And I grew up listening
to all the jazz divas,
the greats like Ella Fitzgerald
and Billie Holiday,
and I never really saw
any female saxophonists.
There's Coltrane and all these
other famous jazz people,
but you know, Lisa Simpson
for me was the one
that made me think, "Girls
can do it, too," you know?
-That makes -- that's so cool.
I want to talk about your
new movie "Misbehaviour."
This is based on a true story
of what happened
at the Miss World competition
in 1970.
A lot of people might not know
the story.
I wasn't that familiar
with the story.
Can you tell everyone
what it's about?
-Yeah, I didn't know
anything about it
until I read the script,
and it's kind of
an amazing story because,
you know, really, in 1970,
it was around the period that
the women's liberation movement
were forming,
and the ceremony itself
was the most watched TV show
in the world.
This particular year in 1970,
the women's liberation movement
stormed the ceremony
in the middle for the feminist
cause and they threw
flower bombs on Bob Hope,
completely disrupted
the whole ceremony,
but it was also the year
that the first woman of color,
Miss Grenada, who I play,
won the competition.
So it's kind of this amazing
intersection of events
between sort of, you know,
the birth of feminism
in the '70s on one hand,
and then this huge step
forward in terms
of representation
for women of color
and perceptions of beauty
on the other.
So, yeah,
it was an amazing year,
and, you know, it's obviously
the '70s fashions and the music
and the era is just really,
really fun
to look back on as well.
-I want to show a clip.
Here is Gugu Mbatha-Raw in
"Misbehaviour." Take a look.
-There will be little girls
watching tonight
who will see themselves
differently because I won,
who might just start to believe
that you don't have to be white
to have a place in the world.
-I'm glad.
I -- I really hope
that the world opens up
for them and for you,
but making us compete with
each other over the way we look,
doesn't make the world narrower
for all of us in the end?
-[ Sighs ]
What's your name?
-Sally.
-Well, Sally,
all I can say is
I look forward to having
your choices in life.
-Gugu Mbatha-Raw, everybody.
"Misbehaviour" is available
on all major digital
and cable platforms today.